we're down to two teams so for double
points what is the name of the purple
Teletubby Susie Winky you're both
correct he always carried red purse max
is very competitive as my it's one of
the reasons I fell in love with him oh
this is easy he was a Incredible Hulk
Eric Bana other one
Mark Ruffalo other one Lou Ferrigno
primal fear Richard Gere never played
the incredible hi Jesus Christ
Norton guys what do you say we do this
at my house next week this will be a
game night to remember oh boy tonight
we're taking game night up a notch we
don't need a board and we do not need
pieces we won't need an extra rudeness
either someone in this room is going to
be taken oh it's an alert a mystery
party fine whoever finds the victim wins
the grand prize the keys to stingray
Josie keys no Ryan the whole car oh yeah
this is why don't we see the best a lot
all right bye baby hand me those matches
about to burn this door down
you're gonna light a fire in a
windowless room that we're trapped in I
gotta make my idea sound stupid you're
not gonna know what's real what's fake
is this John real Oh oh my god
I've always enjoyed the comradery of
good friends stuff and we don't
appreciate what we have until it's gone
oh because your wife left you
[Music]
so much worse okay I've one idea it's so
crazy it just might work
you're gonna crash the car into the
plane like Liam Neeson in taken three he
did that and taken three huh
you missed it thanks baby
this is instructions on how to remove a
bullet didn't have rubbing alcohol so I
got you this lovely sharp good idea way
to pivot what is helpful in Country
Living oh that's the latest there's a
corn chowder recipe looks really good
huh he looks like Jared ooh yeah that's
you
[Music]
you